I'm in - two drafts one with a bunch of
guys who have known here for about 15
years in Los Angeles really want to win
that one really love it last year joined
a new league and I'm back in it again
it's the Alice in Chains fantasy
football league along with the charity
auction and two members of said group
are sitting right here Jerry Cantrell
back here again with Mike Inez good to
see you guys yeah good to be here yeah
you guys were in the finals last year
when we were toda tow now love it Jerry
came here before the finals and we made
a friendly wager okay if Jerry won I had
to wear the rig yeah the rig okay the
whole thing and you got and you were
going to get it from Steel Panther yeah
um I would had to wear the entire rig
for all three hours here on this show
unfortunately that's what happened okay
I don't have a pretty good counter bet -
now the counter bet is the television
audience is seeing the fruits of Jerry's
labor right Marshall oh I did everything
I possibly could to play the part Ron
and I walk around the wall around the
thoroughfare got some coffee yeah I mean
I did the whole thing you rocked the rod
oh I rockin and I rocked the rocks a few
weeks later a little less Atlantic
would've killed a lesser man but the the
had I won had we won sorry Brockman you
you you shot as you're JM you know GM
general because you drafted blind your
ass by the way
yeah one time yeah despite Alan Robinson
killing us all year long but yeah you're
happy Andre Hopkins - yeah where's my
tune let it go right that's why you were
here you would have had to sing an
acoustic version of let it go from
frozen Wow God do a great man he was so
excited I have my gosh that would have
been phenomenal and you know what I
would have done it I know because rappy
was here cleaning up and a janitor rat
before cleaned up in the janitor's
uniform because the week before that was
the bed I forgot what I had to do you
actually played a gig with Steel Panther
then I did sometimes I remember see you
got John Entwistle from the who geezer
butler from Black Sabbath on yourself
well I heard that this is this is what I
love and I told you guys in the
commercial break anytime I Drive
by the Roxy my kids like dad that's
where you played and I'm like yes that's
right dad played Roxy that's right no
one can ever take that away from me
forever or proud so let's talk about
your fantasy football league again
you're going to have a draft on
unfortunately I'm not going to I'm going
to be at the NFL Network working that
night so Brockman you're going to go
there again okay yeah well to September
5th at 5 P at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
once again Sirius XM is going to carry
it live yep right from your house yes of
my house again
yeah damn you may actually do too
because I think Breanna was in our
league as well and he wanted he wanted
us to do another league with him so we
might just need to back to back there no
kidding back to back dress all right
well Fabiano's in it too
you're in it Mike you're in a Duff
McKagan of Guns and Roses yeah Michael
Rapaport Scott in from anthrax Vinnie
Paul Pantera and that is the Miz yeah
Torrey Hori Hori Holden oh yes you
kicked Maurice jones-drew out well you
can or other leave I loved in a lovely I
wish but it's nice to get some new blood
okay we hold it's great right meet and
out of the league anyway yeah yeah and
we'll get to the auction part of it
shortly yeah so how do you feel about
your Seahawks Gerry going into the
season they they they looked great over
the weekend
yeah we're in Los Angeles preseason and
of course God the Chargers didn't look
good but I did like a lot of the younger
that Carson guy was running really good
and I like some of our young receivers
and I thought Boykin played really well
you know what it was I like to yeah it
looks like that they were sick and tired
of beating the crap out of each other in
training camp
yeah practice yeah and that you know
Pete's got the troops all salty he's got
him salty and it looked like the looked
like the Chargers didn't didn't really
care yeah you know I mean it looked like
they were a step behind the whole time
hmm
but it's preseason and you know you
don't you don't know but I'm you know I
think we're fine I mean we've had what
double-digit wins for five or six years
in a row now we've been in the mix right
the program is solid the players are
really good and I like to like a lot of
the new guys that we got so yeah we're
also stuff I think I looking yeah he was
looking good I mean I think lacy really
well that's just a little cup of coffee
for Eddie Lacy we'll see how that looks
like in the Seattle Seahawks are
think I think having him for the for the
length of the season as a as a not maybe
that's not like a full-time back but a
carry carry you know an open a nine-game
at the Green Bay Packer
that's a tough over eight week one yeah
I'm it's a tough open at Lambeau Field
we've got I do believe you have Jordy
Nelson joining us on the show later this
week correct Chris Brockman am i right
if you're telling me that then it's
happening okay we're good you're not on
it you don't know I don't know that you
get the email I think Jordy Nelson is
joining us later on this week I'm Mike
Inez you're wearing a Raiders hat on
what is the what's the background on
that why are you array it's just a team
I was born or raised here in LA and so I
basically grew up watching bow Jack and
Ron that was my childhood team right I'm
really good friends with with Fred and
Angela Biletnikoff so we do the golf
tournament we just read at the Pro
Football Hall of Fame what a good man oh
good human being Belinda Casas they're
just uh what they're doing to in our
charities just next-level really they're
just good people
and everybody who meets them would would
take a bullet for arm through you know
just shows what type of humans they are
that political finance relationship that
nobody ever saw coming yeah and now
you've got one of Jerry's favorite
football players maybe of all time more
yeah I'd student up for you going got it
should have run yeah well instead of oh
I have a feeling it will be sitting on a
poor steel helmet always hold on I'm
sorry
you and Richard Sherman yeah I'm always
going to hold it give it to the Beast
man yeah we were over three times we got
plenty of time
timeout you still can handle it I know
dad back-to-back champion so we're ready
to go with any other team I wouldn't
care but it was to give the Patriots
a Super Bowl they don't need to be given
a Super Bowl you're right okay Rahman
yeah they don't need to be given one why
do we need to show them showing it right
now radio - my heart every to note that
oh my god but we were at the game we
played a lot of their halftime shows
were at the game I guess the Saints
where he did the run yeah we rest we've
heard on the other scale we've been
lucky enough to be so you did at Lima
but Allison change we played the Hat we
played the halftime of the most of the
championship game one we were getting
beat silly by Green Bay and somehow in
the onside kick yeah all of that that we
Alice zero point zero points before we
played all of the points after we I'm
not saying you had a lot to do with it
I'll be handling everything to do with
Hannah and Allison change played
halftime of the Beast quake game - yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah are you gonna do
this you're at any point of the yester I
think if they ask we're always there for
them damn Mecca they always take care of
us
based on that I make I'd make you the
house band come on man I don't think
we'd be here when the Hawks come on give
us a call we haven't played one yet
where they lost I don't think no we
won't we did we did we the first time we
played we did was that where we did we
did Kashmir with the orchestra and that
was Wow
San Francisco came back on like 20-some
points down and fetus brain gorgeous
once ran silly Franco or oh I think is a
we Marshall Fogg was talking about the
other day one Pro Football Hall of Famer
one day he's got the numbers for that I
want to come back in 60 seconds talk
about the the charity aspect of this
because part of it is going to go to I
know music cares or something that's
close to near and dear to your heart to
Jerry and it's really and it's in Chris
Cornell's name it is pretty neat and I
want to talk about that as well as a
couple of fantasy football related
subjects get ready for our draft and
talk a little Alice in Chains with Jerry
Cantrell and my gun as when we come back
here in the Rich Eisen show in a minute
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
fantasy football is in the air and that
means the Alice in Chains fantasy
football league and charity auction is
returning and returning in studio for
another segment it's a bassist Mike Inez
and the man for whom I laid down in last
year's fantasy football final giving him
the win that he's been searching for for
years in his own tournament in his own
charity tournament Jerry Cantrell good
to see both of these right wing and
probably without it against you I wish
it was the other way around quite
frankly although again me and the Steel
Panther rig the the Lexie the like Fox
and rig yeah he's a big Browns fan by
the way
okay yeah I know a lot about the Browns
is something else I can say about that
how did you guys how did you guys hook
up together Jerry and now how did you
were opening for his band in 91 Ozzy
Osbourne and I'll be take us out for
what we were on a tour for what six
months I think so yeah they kept us
honest keep doing yeah thank God along
so well we had those it was on the no
more tears cycle you guys had just
started the dirt album that's right
and a great about great album by the way
oh thank you and your on wasn't too bad
you oh thank you sir we work really hard
at all we do until they uh you got
poached from Ozzy Osbourne's and
essentially what I did I think I'm
wonderful is it does actually like at
the end of their leave that Ozzy damn
yeah yeah and we were we're at the tail
end of like an 18-month world tour hmm
and they were just starting up their
their tour hmm and then so I get this
call we're in the middle of it we were
in the middle of it yeah we decided to
part ways of star in South America we
gave you a call and he said okay oh I'm
up for it yeah so he gets all these
shots for South America and then Mike
wants to do the South American show ya
show so he got sick with all these
immunizations for a couple days yeah I
had like radiator fluid in my veins oh
my god but I made it through and now
here you are so you've been he's been
with us ever since 1991 yeah my I think
the first thing was I think it was we
did like three rehearsals I think it and
then yeah we did I think it was with the
the TV appearances and stuff it was like
27 gay
or something of 32 days in 16 countries
so that was our trial by fire I've got a
good Ozzy story you can lay on melon
what he told you when you told him you
wanted to join them yeah we had mixed
day we were mixing a double live album
we did with Ozzy and we're up in Reno
Nevada in the snow and it's a nice sunny
day snowy day and we're walking at 290 I
got to talk to you so we walked outside
and I said hey Alison chance guys want
me to go to Europe you know and then he
looks me right nice as he says if we
don't if you don't go we have to go to
the hospital and I said why it's going
to take me up them about a week to get
my foot out of your ass she really was
pushing for it he really he said you
seem to get along with those guys great
memories yeah good oh I thought he would
give me a totally cool yeah I mean we
still have a great relationship about
this day
that's great Amelie him well I'm part of
the the charity auction we're going to
get to that right now you're donating
half of the money that you raise over
the next couple of weeks it launches
today right it's already actually up and
running we're about an hour and a half
now it's live for the next ten days half
of the money goes to music for relief in
chester bennington x' named yep and then
half to music cares in Chris Cornell's
name that's right what is what are your
thoughts on the untimely it's been
available these guys horrible year you
know and it's really unfortunate to have
lost those guys but you know doing some
doing something positive in their name
because they were both great people you
know both very good friends and amazing
talents and it just you know still still
doesn't seem real you know but it's good
- it's good to be able to have have fun
with our league to be able to raise
money and you know and be able to give
every year to a charity of the winners
choice so this year the last couple
years we had been partnering with Linkin
Park's charity music for relief so we've
done a few years with those guys and and
so it just made sense to split it up to
music for relief for Chester and I was
already going to donate the money to
music cares and I thought it was
appropriate to make that in Chris
yeah I mean in how are their families
doing it they're dealing you know
they're dealing it's it's just an
unexpected thing and you know we've
we've been through it personally you
know so we kind of know what that's all
about all you can really do is just you
know let everybody know that that you
love them be there for them and and
continue on and also to also to remember
them remember them in a good light
instead of a bad moment you know because
they had great lives and there were
quality people you know and we're so so
many like landmark moments in life
together with Chris you know and I
didn't know Chester as well but but you
know we've read round with him and I'm
remember Barnes and and we've done a lot
of charity work with with he and his
band's charity so you know you just you
just it's it's it's really sad to see
that that sort of thing happened and and
you know just try to be there for them
and and and to be supportive you know
yeah I know it's tough for you to talk
about it's hard to talk I know I could
tell and I know that you know obviously
your is pretty fresh you but you guys
are getting misty-eyed just even even
broaching it you know because especially
with Chris it seemed like he had turned
a corner at least that's what everyone
was talking about and then this whole
thing happened yeah well you know um
moral of the story go to bed make make
the call go to bed go to sleep one one
yeah and yank about it and I think I
think everybody has it already dark
thoughts and I think I think I think
depression and depression and an
addiction
many other issues or they're all linked
you know I have some of them myself
I'm I'm an alcoholic as well so you know
I've dealt with a lot of those issues
myself and we've lost a lot of friends
and bandmates
you know to that but there are a lot of
people that get through that deal and
and so I guess basically is trying to
reach out to them also to be an example
of you can walk through that you know
and because a lot of people were there
for us when we walk through our thing
you know
so it's it's family and it you know it
hurts and I'm really going to miss them
but yeah but and on a bright note though
the kids are fantastic so and with their
kids yeah okay go yeah the kids are
amazing yeah amazing children and
obviously they got a lot of uncles in
the world that helped raise them you
know well let's do that let's raise some
money yeah eBay dot-com slash Alice in
Chains is where people can go right now
Jerry you signed a guitar signed Guns
and Roses bass right yeah those you got
Elton John donated a box for us the
other day which is totally for like
experience last night Mike you signed a
bass a sign snare drum from Vinnie Paul
I'm about to add my two cents right here
yeah I was going to just send you the
shoes but I have this to this yes this
is my football from the Rich Eisen show
week that we spend at the Super Bowl in
Super Bowl 51 okay just reading the
names that are on it right here Kurt
Warner Warren Moon also
Michael Irvin we we have Jim Kelly on
here is well chris burrman stopped by at
the mooch on their Mariucci is on here
Darrell Davis who's now in the Pro
Football event without immunised
ceremony no no no and all his acrobatic
language and so we've got every single
guest that stopped by that we signed and
also I've never done this before I've
never auctioned off a pair of my cleats
that I ran the 40 in at the combine
these are from two years ago they're
gold Under Armor shoes with the name
isin on the side is I I personally did
my magic I have to completely raise some
money so we got shoes I like I said I've
never people always like yeah you should
donate those shoes well my wife is
certainly saying that all the time it's
football signed from the show thank you
these shoes thank you eBay calm slash
Alice in Chains Brockman's come and buy
two draft I will start by seeing that
I'm all here the autumns of items are up
and ready to go right now okay
if you wearing the Lexy wig that night
or rock matte which ass yeah
make me draft well I don't know is that
the duress draft and i'ma gonna head
back around writers liked about last
hour don't fly in the wall on this draft
there's so much going on I'm trying to
stay focused yeah you love to go in
there it was great I was a little over
well I think he loves what's on your
hanging on your wall
yeah maybe else yeah they're still there
by the way they're getting the artwork
this traffic with some things over again
oh is that right they're not just at it
move come on don't recover it on let it
lie you know
what did I say last time they're just
boobs rich recent make a t-shirt like
that we're just boobs rich they're just
been on the back they're just boobs
good to see you Jerry come back any time
obviously okay Mike your first maiden
voyage here on the show came as well
Jerry Cantrell Mike Inez of Allison
change again ebay.com / Allison chains
check out all the exclusive items and
experiences that are there and obviously
it goes for a great cause we're back
with your calls and wrapping up the show
and set up the rest of the week and I
guess breaking news - Chris Brockman
who's actually on this show that's
coming up you sir Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app don't have any memory
on your phone let's start to delete some
of those slo-mo videos you have and you
know which ones I'm talking about